[Music]
[Music]
I'm playing the long game I always have
it's why a lot of you have good
relationship with me I see you at
different places I know who you are I
care and interact with you like life is
simple like the truth wins you may be
confused because times are tough in the
media and there's always issues in this
country we got flaws and all that stuff
you're more than welcome to look at the
pessimistic aspects of society and life
I choose to in my 8090 years hopefully
on earth to understand it I got to be a
human being which if you want to talk
about big data map the rarity of
actually becoming a person is insane 400
trillion to one I just want everybody
here this this is a reason I'm happy
24/7 365 for the rest of my life four
hundred trillion to one the odds of
becoming a human being it's the only way
I think about it like what the [ __ ] is a
matter of people in the most macro it's
futile deserve to be here like and I
like to use the word deserve because
like that makes it like it's ridiculous
like it's ridiculous
something ridiculous yeah you know I
just I'm going to struggle to the day I
die of allowing yourself to look at
glass half-empty and now I understand
its DNA and its wiring and you know if
you grow up with a mother who's
extremely negative it's a really tough
situation of Regatta but just proven
I've understood you grow up in a tough
town I get it there's a couple of issues
with that number one nobody cares I kind
of really want people to pull over right
now if you look at that mirror rear view
mirror I don't I guess I thought you
look at it you need to understand if you
look at it it's your fault really not
everything in life is on you that's the
big punchline like everybody's got stuff
the problem is nobody cares and once you
understand that nobody cares and you're
complaining to empty air you start going
in a little bit of a different direction
and yeah I mean I try to I like putting
out positivity what's happening right
now is
small minority of people that are mad
and angry and hateful and dark are much
louder than the big percentage of us
that are happy and excited and feel
great and because the way technology
works they are much louder than they've
ever been before and so I feel like if
somebody who's got full of bright light
and happiness that I need to start
getting louder about that as well
because that's the only way we're going
to come back
and you know what that right there in
real time is what it's all about because
if that's the thing that's going to get
the clouded clap so far from this
conversation that's what we need to be
focusing on I want to be on the offense
of positivity not dwell and to
understand how we got here there's only
so much I can do about being happy and
documenting my happy journey I'm trying
to pressure the other people that are
happy to talk about it - I just think
we're in a very awkward time I think
it's rubbernecking and it's just the way
it is right like you pay more attention
to the negative than the positive it's
just how I feel about the world like
nice things I think human beings are the
most underrated thing of all time when I
think about our capabilities to
eliminate each other I'm being serious I
know it's kind of a weird place to go
but like the fact that were still - here
we are hard-wired in a way that allows
us to protect each other in a net game
negativity is a lot easier to sell
that's why it's working
like what I do for a living is much
harder I'm trying to win on positivity
which is the hardest sell I feel more
responsibility than ever as somebody who
is happy and wants other people to be
happy genuinely to get louder and so
it's an interesting time in our
country's history and just in human
society and so if you leave with
anything for any of us please please
take on the sense of responsibility that
if you've got good and you feel good to
start sharing that content as well
because the world needs more of it
[Music]
you
[Music]